hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the 1972 World Chess Championship
match between boris moiseevich basking
in the robert james fisher
now if you've been with us so far you
know that Fischer for the first time won
a game against Boris Spassky it was not
on the main stage of the playing call in
Reykjavik Iceland but rather it was in
the backstage that room was primarily
you know designed to be like a relaxing
room like a ping-pong room where you
would hang out and play some sports and
it was definitely not fit to play a
World Chess Championship match in so
spotted complaining after that while
playing the game he could hear a noise
from the outside he could hear children
laughing children playing he could hear
the traffic noise he could hear
dogs barking and although he didn't file
a formal protest he did say that he will
not be playing any more games in the
backstage room and okay that was I mean
that was to be expected but Fischer also
filed a formal protest saying that he
will not still not be playing if there
are any cameras around him but luckily
chief arbiter loader Schmidt noticed
that the formal protests delivered by
Fischer was not signed by Fischer
himself and this is something that was
not according to rules and he could
completely nullify this this Fischer's
appeal so Fischer had no choice but
agreed to play on the main stage but
still they only used that one camera
that Fischer didn't find it the closed
circuit one although fish are still
complained that even though he couldn't
actually hear it he said that he could
sense it and I mean it's not completely
not understandable III mean I can
imagine some people would have problems
concentrating and really putting their
self into the game if they knew they
were being broadcasted on a large screen
in front of a lot of people if you
remember if you remember George Waitzkin
he had similar problems after they made
a movie about his life searching for
Bobby Fischer he said that he could no
longer focus on the game
he couldn't have
his entire thought thought process into
the game because he was constantly
thinking about how he how he appeared to
the outside audience so I don't know it
does kind of make sense but Fisher yeah
didn't really mind at the cameras he
didn't mind if the cameras were
recording their board but he had a
problem if the camera was recording him
so he asked if if the television how
house could somehow notify him when the
camera was recording in the board and
when the camera was recording him as it
didn't really have a good way of solving
this Chester Fox offered an idea to
water Schmidt and said that perhaps we
could give a signal to the players
either either via a sound signal or
maybe just signal eyes it somehow but
that idea didn't seem very attractive to
Fisher or to Spassky so they just
decided not to go with it but okay now
after everything was said and done no
one could really no one could really say
if Fischer will show up for the fourth
game of the match but as the fourth game
started Fischer had two white pieces and
for the fourth game Fischer was actually
there on time and as usual when Fischer
has the white pieces he opens with E for
and in the previous encounters between
Fischer and Spassky spots usually
replied e five but here as possibly
prepared something very special and he
played c5 the Sicilian defense and he
decided to challenge Fischer where
fishery strongest in his own favorite
variation in the sauce and attack
against the Sicilian so I really really
enjoyed preparing this game free and I
hope you'll enjoy it as much as I
enjoyed preparing it so let's dive
straight into it Knight to f3
we have d6 d4 C captures night capture
sent Knight to f6 all pretty standard
Knight to c3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
c4 we have the source an attack on the
board east six and Bishop to b3 so again
we transpose into the Sherman England
variation Bishop to e7 and here Fischer
did play a game in the 1962
in Cracow against none other than effing
Geller and here Fischer continued with
f4 he lost that game to a from the other
and as we've already mentioned effing
Geller is along with nikolai grabbe spaz
the second for this role Chess
Championship match
so Geller of course knows this very well
and by him by that but by that
comparison
Spassky knows this as well as his his
second so Fischer came prepared
he plays Bishop to e3 an improvement on
his f4 idea we have castles and here
again Fischer castles as you remain if
you remember from the while we were
covering the 1970 palma de mallorca
inter-zonal here Fischer continued Queen
to e2 against the bent Larsen and you
all know that there was a one of when
one of the games that Fischer did not
win in the opponent America inter-zonal
rather it was the only game she lost
there but okay again an improvement by
Fisher here Fisher castles we have a six
and only now f4 here
Spassky could simply continue developing
let's say Bishop to d7 rook to b8 but he
decides to go with a more active idea
knife captures on d4 okay we have Bishop
captures on d4 enter now Bishop to b5
preparing to develop his LightSquared
bishop and also an idea is to play b4
and dislodge Fisher's Knight from c3
from where he is defending the e4 pawn
okay we have a three Fischer stops
before but trip to b7 and now comes
Queen to d3 and here this has only moved
13 but here you will see how well
prepared Spassky came to this game
because in 1959 in the USSR championship
effing Geller had a disposition this
exact position with the black pieces
against nicoleff scheme and here in
Keller played Queen to c7 and the later
when he held and analyzed the game he
said he didn't really like this passive
approach with black so here he and
Spassky prepared a very deadly variation
with the black pieces here they prepared
a five and you can see how much
preparation went into it because then in
the pre engine era they play they
prepared the move that is actually the
strongest move recommended by the angel
so what's the idea here well
official plan was to push f5 here
pushing f5 wouldn't really work all that
much because now black can push a for
after he dislodges the bishop then comes
a five and here black would be a black
would be a very black would stand very
well here after better moves you can can
simply continue developing route to c8
but there is the other question after a
five why not simply capture the b5 pawn
well if you capture the knight capture
some b5 then you no longer are defending
d4 square black can simply capture it
and you don't want to give you give up
your central pawn for a beep on on the
other hand after this if I move you
could play Queen captures but then you
get Bishop to a6 and you lose the
exchange here although this this might
not actually be so bad for white because
white can go Queen g5 and after captures
captures white does keep a bishop pair
and it's not all that easy to break
through here for black for example you
can't push a for the Bushman tonight are
controlling it very nicely
the bishop prepare the night.the the
well-placed the rook rook and coming to
the attack white is definitely not worse
here but it would take perhaps a McHale
towel to go into a variation like this
although even he wouldn't go wouldn't do
this against the boris spassky so okay
after a5 Fisher finds a different idea
since the move he fears the most is
actually before that would dislodge his
defender of d4 school efore pawn from
simply pushes 85 d4 pawn is no longer a
target and now he will question
spassky's idea of actually keeping this
pawn unguarded so okay what happens here
d characters on e5 with an F captors on
e5 Knight to d7 and now Fischer says
simply okay Knight captors on b5 I'm up
a pawn what's your plan here here comes
a move that both him him and Geller
prepared Knight to c5 so here you have
the idea behind the pawn sacrifice
Spassky will definitely win the bishop
prepare either Fischer will capture with
the bishop and give up the dark square
Bishop or he will move the Queen as the
Queen is under attack
and then Spassky will grab the light
square Bishop so Fischer decides to give
up the dark square Bishop we have Bishop
captures on c5 Bishop captures on c5
this comes with check rook to King to h1
and here even though as bosque had this
very well prepared and definitely had
this on the board in his home
preparations we have a very interesting
moment here where Spassky goes into a
very long thing very hard to imagine but
if you remember when we covered the
towel versus Botvinnik series botanique
also in variations that he had during
his home preparation he also would spend
some 10 to 15 minutes as if he was just
you know checking it during the actual
game itself but okay here as poss you
can definitely trade Queens if he
decides to trade Queens
then after C captures let's say better
up to a6 attacking the knight Knight c7
attacking rook and Bishop rook moves
knife captures rook captures Bishop to
c4 attacking the rook rook moves and now
b3 but if you really look at the
position ok black is better even though
white is upper piece but passkeys Bishop
is very nicely controlling all the all
the breakthroughs squares he can easily
just put his rooks on the B and D file
and there is no real way for white to
break through but there really aren't
any chances for spots key to push for
the win here either so instead of this
Queen captures on d3 which is most
likely what he was working out when he
was spending such a long time thinking
he decides to go Queen to g5
so as Fischer won his the previous game
Game three with the black pieces here
Spassky also wants to go for the win
the threat is Queen captures on g2
checkmate so Fischer has to prevent this
Fischer place Queen to e2 prevents the
checkmate and now comes Luke 8 to d8
we have located the 881 recapture Sunday
one look at for Sunday 1 and although
official was the one spending a lot of
time in the opening Spassky spent some
maybe some 5 minutes whereas Fischer
spent over half an hour here it was
actually Spassky who was down on time
what if you look at the position I'm
pretty sure you can agree that the pawn
sacrifice is a
very well justified as the strong bishop
pair is eyeing future skin here this
bishop pair it's really a monster bishop
pair the queen is very nicely placed on
g5 and if Spassky can get this rook into
attack it will be truly an overwhelming
attack so how does possibly go about
this well he pushes h5 first as he does
have the very strong brush repairing the
king it makes sense to try and push h4
and h3 and okay Fischer pushes not plays
Knight to d6 a very nice move you don't
really gain anything by capturing it you
really do need your Bishop air here
brush up to a 8 and now comes Bishop to
c4 Fischer says you don't really have
anything here I'm just gonna slowly
build up my attack if you try and
prevent it output b3 if you don't I can
even push C 3 b3 and b4 or better yet B
3 C 3 and B 4 somehow try to get my
pawns rolling on the Queen side and
suppose he pushes h4 of course it would
be ideal if you can get a ch3 and but
Fischer will not allow that h3 by
Fischer himself and now comes the
absolute best Mumbai Spassky Bishop to
e3 the ideal placement would be Bishop
to a for Queen to g3 and Queen to H to
checkmate
but of course Fischer has something to
say about this as well rook to d3 would
not be so great
yes you are threatening to capture the
bishop and you are keeping an eye on the
g3 square but Bishop to f4 now and you
tend to defend your a 5 points possible
equalizing material and you he will be
left with a better position so instead
after Bishop to e3 we have Queen to g4
by Fisher Fisher offers the trade of
Queens and here Spassky simply grabs the
e5 pawn Queen captures on e5 Spassky
flies in material but not for long as
Fischer grabs
d h e4 pawn also Spassky before
capturing d5 pawn he had to figure out
that night captors on f7 was not really
a threat it seems like a winning idea
for example rook captures rook e8 check
King moves and Bishop to d3 you can't
move the King because you get rogue to a
trade so we'd have to block with the
rook and then rook captures on a on a 8
and now you will simply capture on f5
and win the game problem is after Knight
captures on f7
Spassky can simply play
captors on f7 and now there's really no
good continuation here for white you
simply gave up a night for nothing
so after Queen to e5 the Fisher plays
Queen captures on h4 and grabbing the
pawn again and here Spassky plays an
absolute brilliant move g5 would this
move g5 officially no longer has a
control of the da square and Spassky
really wants to play rook to d8 to
oppose Fischer's to work on d1 official
plays Queen to g4 as he can't really
give up the control of this diagonal and
allow Spassky to play Queen to g3 and
also sets a trap for Spassky if Spassky
no does continue with this rook to d8
moved then Fischer can indeed play but
Knight captures on f7 and after rook
captures and e1 Queen captures King
Capra's on f7 now Queen to d7 is enough
to claim a draw by by repetition of
moves
for example King moves Queen dat check
you can simply Queen East 7 check
Queenie 8 check and simply keep checking
and if black tries anything to get out
of the check he can even lose the game
so after Queen to g4 Bishop to c5 again
a best move by Spassky attacking
Fischer's night here and here Fischer
plays Knight the b5 it's the best idea
although the knight is currently
somewhat out of the game there really
isn't a better move King to g7 Spassky a
low on time tries to end the game we are
via the maneuver rook to HH to h4 but
Fischer is just in time to prevent this
he goes night to d4 now rook to h8 will
be met with Knight to f3 and from f3 the
night will be covering the covering the
h4 square and here we have a critical
moment in the game
Spassky plays rook to a trade in his
book League which mentions that Ruby h8
is a very strong move but rook to d8 is
the move that will allow Spassky to win
the game why rope to d8 is better than
rook to h8 it's not all that all that
easy to see especially under under time
pressure but to understand rope to d8
we're just gonna have to check out what
happens after look to h8 of course now
rook to h4 is an idea so Fisher has to
play
to f3 which happens in the game now as
Pascal really doesn't want to play rook
to h4 4c captures on f3 we have Queen
captures on f3 and then out comes a rope
to h4 sorry not immediately roofed h4
doesn't work because of the g4 I mean it
is a it is a better continuation than
what's pasta played in the game in the
game Spassky played Bishop to b6 which
threatens checkmate but it allows
Fischer this Queen to c3 idea which was
played in the game and with this move
Fischer forces a trade of Queens and now
that you see what happened in the game
you will be able to understand better
why after Knight study for a rook to d8
was better than rook to h8 Rock the d8
simply a triple attack against the night
you do have to prevent this only good
way to prevent it is c3 and only now
after fish replace c3 you play rook - h8
and now the same variation doesn't work
for Fischer because Quintus III would a
trade of Queens will be impossible
because there is a pawn on c3 but it's
not all that you know black and white
Fischer will still have this try of
Bishop captures on e6 and now if you
capture you will get Knight captures on
e6 with check King moves Knight captures
on c5 and now you are you are unable to
capture the night because if you capture
Queen e6 elites the checkmate ok most
Queen checks here King moves Queen
checks here and after King moves simply
looked at e7 and you are getting
checkmated the problem is after this
maneuver of Bishop captures on e6f
Capra's on e6 you don't capture
immediately but rather first and in
between Bishop captures on d4 see
captures and only now Queen captures
Queen captures on g5 which checked under
now Queen has to block Queen check here
and now if you move along for example f8
or along g8 then white can keep checking
you on this dark square diagonal so we
have to block with the Queen Queen f6
Queen the g3 check King to h6
and now d5 this is a
pretty much forced if you wanna save the
game with white the idea is roped the d4
to h4 with a win so black of course will
not allow this Queen to g5 and here you
have the trade Queens queen capture skin
captures into now before a captures a
capture some before and here you have a
position where Spassky has an extra
piece but Fischer has three three points
for the piece the coordination between
the Fischer's rook and all of these
pawns isn't all that great so it would
be it would be very hard to save this
for white
that's why League which says that in
this position worked the d8 followed by
rook th it was much better than repeated
what was played in the game but in time
pressure I don't think anyone could find
this but okay we have Knight to f3
characters captures as we already said
rook Bishop to d6 threatening checkmate
here but here goes also men mentions
that rope to h4 might have been a better
try and now if you just move the bishop
as the bishop is under attack you're
gonna get rook to f4 so you do have to
block it and only now you play Bishop to
d6 and now Queen to c3 with the with the
trade of Queens doesn't work because you
also have to keep an eye on the h2 h3
pawn so now Queen to g2 and now the
White Queen is stuck guarding the h3
pawn but also the checkmate on h2 and it
would be it would be impossible to play
this for white so again another lack of
you know lapse of judgment for a for
Spassky but all in time trouble but
should to b6 now Fischer as we already
mentioned trade trades Queens here Queen
captures pawn captures and now Spassky
could capture on a3 but it only
simplifies the position for example
Bishop captures rook to a-1 attacking
the bishop bishop here captures
threatening the g5 pawn you have to
protect it and now whatever you play
black will eventually capture the c3
pawn and would equal material on the
board and opposite colored the bishops
it's it's a dead to draw so after Bishop
the c3 Spassky tried a different
approach of Bishop to e5 but it's pretty
much all the same our up to D 7 the
threat this Bishop captures on e6 King
to f6 we have King to g1 Bishop captures
on c3 Bishop to e2 Bishop to e5 King to
f1 and the now rook to see it the the
only way
Spassky can get the rook into the game
is to move it away from the H file but
as soon as he does this Fischer takes
advantage of it goes brush up to h5
threatens the D f7 pawn I you can't
allow this to happen so rook to c7 we
have rook captures the Metro captors and
now it's simply opposite colored bishops
it's a dead draw a fourth Fisher simply
puts upon on a light square as basket
has a dark square Bishop King to e7 King
to e to F five with King to d3 Bishop to
e5
we have c4 King to d6 Bishop to f7 and
after butter to g3 Fischer played c5
offering a trade here if King captures
then Bishop captures here and it was in
this position on a move 45 that both
Fischer and Spassky agreed to a draw so
a very impressive game and you can
really see how much history and
preparation went into into Spassky
challenging fishery in his favorite line
in the line that he strongest in the
line where he defeated a lot of a lot of
strong grandmasters so very impressive
and you can really see how useful his
second f'ing Geller is in preparing him
for these games so like I said I really
enjoyed preparing this game I also I
really hope you enjoyed it as well and I
do hope you're enjoying the Fischer
series so far I would like to thank John
Welsh Alejandro mooska Simon North Hall
you'll be ensuring and chase Bailey for
a contribution wait to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
to answer a chase Bailey's question
Avantika perhaps is not my favorite
chess player but he is definitely in the
top three Sam once again that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with another
interesting video thank you all and I'll
see you soon